[Music]
now what about cutting so let's take
this back to the beginning frame one put
this back to the end frame close enough
these don't look exact oh that's way off
but okay whatever so say
i'm going to just show you cuts first so
you have to select the files you want to
cut
and then there's a couple different ways
to cut there's a soft cut and a hard cut
and k
is the hotkey so if you just want to do
a cut you can just press k now you can
also right click
and go to split and boom it'll split the
files so you can move them around
separately
and you can see there it'll overlap a
little bit like that if it's doing that
it'll snap
as you can see now that was a soft cut
just doing that split is a soft cut and
what that means
when it's a soft cut is you're given
some freedom
for repairing your little timeline you
see these little light gray edges you
can click those
i'm actually going to do a control click
so i get both of them
the sound and the video and you can just
move that if you have it highlighted you
can move it so a soft cut
allows you to extend plus the place
where you cut so now we actually get
duplicate video like from here to here
is going to repeat twice because we
extended it i'm going to hit control z
to undo that change
all right so soft cut allows you to
extend past
where you cut
that's the big thing about the soft cut
it's very forgiving for lining things up
so now let's drag this back over all
right well that's fine we're just going
to leave that now let's talk about hard
cut so let's go somewhere else
and select both of these
if you just do split it doesn't do
anything unless you haven't selected so
it only splits the one you select so you
press k
now the other option is shift k you
don't see that here because it's not as
common but if you're doing something
like changing the speeds
and uh doing
uh speed up fast forward slow down you
do need to do these hard cuts but if
you're not doing those you don't need to
worry about it so
to hard cut it's shift k
and looks like that's now called hold
split so they've changed those names and
the old versions they were
soft cut and hard cut now it's split and
hold split so the hold split we'll do
that
let's move this over a little bit we're
going to find that even if you click
these ends with control click it's not
going to let us extend see it has this
like
dark gray area
it's just going to be like a paused area
that is just a freeze frame of
the first frame of whatever so it
doesn't let you repair your video in
that way but it does allow for some
freeze frame action
and
that's kind of cool sometimes so i'm
going to go ahead and undo that
and i think you probably get how to do
the cuts and move things around and
extend the beginnings ends and like line
them up that's like you know 99 of the
work sometimes when you're just doing
some basic stuff like maybe you have
this awful section where you said
something you don't want out there so
you're just like all right
i'm going to shift k there
i'm going to shift k there
and i'm just going to get rid of this
section so you do that
by just highlighting that section and
pressing delete now i did a hard cut
here and i did a hard cut here so i'm
not going to be able to re-extend back
into it it's just going to do freeze
frames if i do that ctrl z to undo
so let's say
this section right here
we want to maybe
speed this up all right so i'm going to
show you how to do a speed up now this
only works if you have hard cuts on
either edge so this edge needs to be a
hard cut
this edge needs to be a hard cut
otherwise this the speed thing is going
to be wonky
so
getting the volume or the sound right
with your speedups is a little weird too
but you can do it
all right so you click on this main
video here
and let's go ahead and mess with the
time a bit so you can go over here to
the right this is the properties of your
currently selected clip okay so when you
click on this you get those properties
of your currently selected clip
and let's just look through these a
little bit there's transform
which allows you to reposition
everything and scale and
rotate origin you can do those with soft
or hard cuts that's fine but you can
play around with these a little bit and
you can actually see what happens there
visually so these are more things you
can play around with a bit uh for your
video editing creativity i'm just going
to hit on doing all of these
there we go
all right and then we have crop
which is going to let you cut off some
of one of the sides or something like
that
this can be handy for
uh doing like split screen stuff maybe
you want one on this side and you bring
in another video and you put it on the
other side you can do something like
that with crop all right we're just to
set this back to zero
but uh i mainly want to get to this time
but we'll get to it there's video a
strobe i never mess with this i'm not
sure what it does 100 color you can just
change well the saturation is going to
be kind of a black and white effect or
super color
and multiply it's going to make it
really bright or just disappear entirely
so
leave those default but you can mess
around with those at some point okay so
it's not over here
but there are some important things it's
not it's really good to know about those
mostly transform crop
and this color are probably what you're
going to use you probably don't want to
mess with the time and source and other
stuff all right and there's a
compositing we'll probably come back to
the sum this is actually somewhat
important right now it's set to cross
the most intuitive way to use this blend
in my opinion is actually with overdrop
because that makes basically if you're
doing
some layers of videos over drop will
make the one on top visible first
basically so
often when i'm layering stuff i'll be
switching the top the ones higher up to
overdrop otherwise they're not going to
reveal stuff behind it so that's going
to be a little weird let me do another
example let me just show you uh i will
get to the timing stuff i just uh don't
want to skip over this so i'm going to
shift k here i'm just going to grab
another section of video more shift k
here
and let's say i don't want the audio on
this one so keep the audio there
click and hit delete and now this piece
of video say i want to bring this up
into its own timeline and then maybe i
want to shrink it and do a little
picture and picture so let's click over
here so we can see what's going on
right now what's going on it's going to
play the audio the one behind it but
when it gets to here it's you're going
to get overlay of this video so
this video is going to be on top
so we can click this let's go to
transform
and let's just scale it down a little
bit
0.7 is good so now the one on top is
smaller but as you can see there's
uh this checkerboard behind which
basically means it's going to be nothing
or black
so you you would think you would see
this video behind it right and the
reason you don't is because this is set
to crop you need to set it to overdrop
and then it'll show the ones behind it
so that's the point of that you can see
you'll do this with pictures if you're
bringing in like pngs and stuff
you can play around with these some but
typically you're going to be using stuff
like overdrop
and
that should be it the opacity
you can
make it fade in and out or be half
visible
can be used for effects if you're for
example layering two of the same scene
and you want to make someone disappear
like they're a ghost
you could use something like this
opacity to fade them out
and that gets into key framing uh we'll
come back to keyframing it's kind of
complicated i want to finish talking
about um speeding up a video so let's
say we just want to speed up this little
section here that we over dropped you
can do this to anything really
uh we're also just going to move the
position a little bit up here
now let's just totally sample
kind of you know whatever
so say we want to speed this up we do
need hard cuts on the side so let's just
double check yep we got a hard cut there
we got a hard cut there so
now there someone's probably gonna ask
me about these keys i just click the
edge get it highlighted press the g key
for grab it's a blender hotkey g
and it'll give you these little arrows
that let you start moving it and when
you click left click again it snaps it
into place if you press escape
it cancels so that's all it's doing
there's hitting g and then escape
all right so let's speed this up to
speed these up you need to add an effect
strip so we're going to get into a
little bit about effect strips all right
so you click on it
you go up here
to add
and then we want effect strip
and we'll see a couple specific ones
transform speed control
transform is essentially the same as
this except you get another set of
transform properties so you can like
layer them
uh usually not necessary but we're
looking at speed control speed control
so you're welcome to play around with
all those because i'm not going to talk
about all of them there's just too many
but speed control is going to put the
property on whatever you had selected so
it's going to put that speed control
property on that clip we had selected
there
and uh as you can see
it's
there it's kind of hard to
visually make out
and it is defaulted to overdraw if this
doesn't default to overdrop you might
have to change it otherwise it's
going to do something else so now what
we want to do is just
is just change this speed now the way
this works
but now if you grab an edge
and extend it out
it's gonna
slow down the clip it's gonna basically
match that small section and extend it
out to that via slo-mo
so it's hard to see here but
if i just hit spacebar you'll probably
see a little better you can see this is
a slow-mo
going thing
so
yeah maybe you don't want that right
there but
that's how you do slow-mo basically is
you just put that speed control over
something that's hard cut on both sides
and extend it out if you want to if you
want to make it faster
you do the same thing except you bring
it in and it should zip through
as you can see it's going super fast
there
it's hard to tell in this particular
video but yeah look at this
there you go
so it's going a little faster it's gonna
shrink down via speed up
to whatever you want so we could play
the whole clip super cl quick by doing
this and we'll just
there we go
so maybe we want that i don't know i'm
just doing random effects here there's
really no method to the madness just
kind of showing you stuff so we could
have a sped up clip over top in the
corner by just layering some of these
effects and there we go
yeah we don't have the sound the sound
is gone right so that's a thing
and that's something that's kind of
tricky to get right and it's going to
take some trial and error typically
if you're speeding up or slowing down a
clip just delete the audio
because
well let me let me grab another section
so shift k here we've got another hard
cut area let's click this go add
effect strip
speed control
and now we got the audio alongside it
for now
so this audio
is going to be tricky
but basically what you got to do is you
got to use this pitch
i think it's changed from the way i
remember it
basically
say okay this is
how many frames is this all right let's
let's we got to do a little math
sometimes because not everything's
automatic with blender sometimes you got
to kind of custom do it
you can see that the duration is 10
seven ten one seven seven so it's that
many frames ten thousand one hundred
seventy seven
[Music]
all right so maybe we wanna make this
double speed so we'll cut the frames in
half
on this thing
which would be about
i don't know let's pull up a calculator
so actually we can
do this
fast way just hit undo a few times
if you go to this duration
and you just go to the end of it and
press and hit divide by two
boom it'll just do it for you it'll set
it to exactly half the best you can
now we can do the same with this audio
duration
divide by two
and we have the audio matching but the
audio isn't sped up or slowed down now
until we hit this pitch
so i believe you just gotta
if you half the duration
you're gonna half the pitch and we
should now get a match putting on my
headphones so i can test
all right so we should get
oh i might have done this backwards
that would be a slow down pitch
so since we're speeding up the audio we
want to up the pitch this is going to
sound a little weird
it's going to be chipmunky basically
and it looks like it's lagging me out a
little bit
yeah so it's uh it's if you've got
layered effects in this
timeline thing and it's going to be
pretty slow that's normal as it catches
up with all your effects
and there we go
the audio matches it's sped up and
pitched up
that's essentially how you do it
so if you get stuck study that carefully
but also
no one's going to care a lot of times
what people do is just delete the audio
put a little music behind it or
something that's fine but if you must
have your audio with it that's how you
do it and it's the same for splitting
speed up for slow down
if you extend it to double what it was
yeah so speeding or putting this pitch
up is for speed up
put it down slow down now there's
something weird about the pitch
uh there might be more ways to adjust it
to not be so chip monkey but i'm not
sure and i'm not gonna get into it
that's basically
[Music]
[Music]
you